all right
good evening good morning to everybody
here
this is a very very special day and in
these days where
there is not a lot of positivity around
i want to welcome you to them
and i welcome you to this convocation
for the purdue
uh graduates this is really really a big
deal
and you should be very very proud of
what you've achieved today we're also
joined today by a lot of senior folks
from purdue and from simply learn and we
will have them speak for a few minutes
as well
and agenda today is very simple
acknowledge appreciate
all the amazing work that's gone into
you actually being here today and
achieve this
outcome so we'll have a very short
ceremony we'll get to a place where you
know we
call out you know all the successes
you've had we'll show you a sense of
what's coming next
and we'll go from there all right let's
actually start with the first part now
first of all i want to i want to
commend everybody here this is a journey
this is a journey of absolute
true grit and i'll tell you this myself
my team puts together this portfolio
this curriculum that people have to go
through and i will tell you it is a very
difficult program to complete and the
fact that you're all
here having completed almost six to ten
months of weekend lessons in addition to
your day jobs and
your family lives and everything that
goes on around there 100 plus
hours of learning 20 plus assessments
and project and then one month of an
intense capstone project done
to achieve this possibility is an
absolutely amazing journey and by the
way as a person whose michael's gone
through weekend classes
i cannot be more proud of all of you
every one of you is an absolute achiever
to have reached this point
and i commend you and i appreciate
everything you've done so big round of
applause a virtual applause for all of
you
who have made it this far this is a
journey of absolute true grit
and i also want to talk about the folks
who have actually made it here you
should know who your
peers are who your cohort members are so
why don't we go to the next one
so the other thing i wanted to call out
this has been a journey that you've made
with some pretty amazing peers and i'll
just give you a sense of the folks that
are here today
literally 33 43
of your batchmates actually have at
least a bachelor's degree
33 of you have a master's degree and so
one thing you know
proudly that we can say we have got one
of the best goals by the way you will
always be a very special cohort for us
you are literally the first cohort that
is actually graduating from this program
and so that basically puts you in a more
special place for simply learn and
prepared you
where you are the first to actually come
out of these programs and you know
show the success that can be possible
but look around you and look at the
people that have been there
literally everybody hasn't been
achievers
you people from electronics in
communication computer science marketing
finance every single background that you
can think of and if you look at the
number of years
on average that people have brought to
the table you'll find that a vast
majority of the folks that are here have
at least eight plus years of experience
so this is definitely not uh you can
also add physicians wonderful thing
that's a great one prayer but this is
not a group of slouches this is a group
of
absolute achievers that's made it this
far and i've achieved this dream of
actually getting the certification
and passing with spine colors across
multiple programs
so congratulations this is an amazing
cohort and later on we'll talk about how
you can stay in touch with your cohort
and get the benefits of the purdue
alumni association as well
uh this is an amazing group do not lose
track of that and stay in touch with
your cohort pushers and congratulations
to this cohort
you were achievers before you came
you're even greater achievers now that
you have exited this program
all right let's go to the next slide
i want to introduce you to the guest of
honor today uh dr patrick wolf and he's
just
one of the most amazing people you will
meet if you meet him in person
by the way before i talk about all his
great achievements let me also talk
about how much of a
what a humble person he is as well i've
had the pleasure of actually interacting
with him a few times and have always
been struck by the kind of humility he
brings to the table
but just to give you a sense of what
he's achieved right he's a presidential
early career award for scientists and
engineers
at the white house right no less he's a
distinguished lecturer in data science
you know you know certified by triple
ieee in 2018
he served as a royal society research
fellow and is the founding executive
director of ucl's big data institute
worked as a faculty member at cambridge
harvard and university college in london
and received his phd from the university
of cambridge in 2003
uh dr patrick it's a real pleasure to
have you here
and i'd love for you to you know tell
our graduates uh you know give your
thoughts on how they can take their
career forward and what they have
achieved today
over to you anand thank you
and uh i've just turned on my video so
hopefully it'll be
uh it'll be showing for everyone pretty
quickly here
um and uh can i just checking on that
you can hear me and everyone else can
hear me well
yes yes patrick we can hear you
excellent can you also see me or not yet
we can do both uh patrick please go
ahead excellent
yeah so thank you everybody and and
thank you for those in the chat for uh
for feeding back on that
and i i am i sincerely hope that anand
hasn't uh oversold me here
um today is is is is not at all in any
way about me
it's about it's about you and uh you
know i think really the first thing to
say
is just to echo echo the introduction
that anon made
and and say what an achievement it is
and what an accomplishment it is to have
graduated from this program
and on top of everything else it's been
one of the most
unusual years uh in at least a century i
think around the world
and you know thank goodness we have the
the
um you know the the telecommunications
and computing
infrastructure to be able to to complete
online and virtual programs like this uh
in a way that is
is is much much easier in a time of of
coronavirus
than it would be if we all had to to
physically meet
on evenings or weekends so
i want to talk a little bit about purdue
and why we chose uh to get engaged with
simply learn
and to participate in this effort
we have a a a hard-earned
a reputation i think as an institution
that is strong
in research uh uh and very pragmatic
and practical um humble about uh
the achievements of our alums but um
but proud of each and every one of them
and
uh and absolutely 100 behind
everything that we can do to launch each
and every one of you
successfully into the next uh into the
next phases of your careers
i've personally had the pleasure of
not only looking over the program
content in in strong detail
but in hosting several master classes
over the past year
and uh we just concluded uh the most
recent one
uh just the other day about the
importance
of um you know the explainable
explainability and transparency of
modern day algorithms and we
we touched on everything from clinical
trials for coronavirus vaccines
uh to what can go wrong when algorithms
and data science techniques
are used to for example you know
help court judges to um you know to
recommend
you know length of criminal sentences
and things like that
so there is an incredible world that's
now open to all of you
having um you know having learned what
you've learned
and achieved what you've been able to
achieve uh over the course of this
um of this sequence of modules so we're
incredibly proud and we stand 100
behind you um in particular uh
knowing that you've got a credential
that's backed by purdue
i think it will help you um as a calling
card not only because people recognize
the quality and the reputation
of the training that we help to provide
but also because
you'll now have access to a worldwide
network
network of purdue alums and i've had the
good fortune to travel the world
and meet so many of our alums all across
the globe
and as soon as international travel
picks up again
i i fully intend to um you know to come
out and and pay a visit
hopefully to at least some of you uh as
you go off uh on to the next challenges
and opportunities in your own on your
own careers
um so um i want to talk just a little
bit about
sort of two more things uh in the spirit
of keeping
uh you know graduation speeches very
brief um
i think it's important and we talked
about this on our last master class
it's important now to recognize that
you're on the other side of the table
you've graduated from this program and
you have
uh both an opportunity and a
professional responsibility
um you know to begin to add to the
broader global data science community
you know using your hard-won expert
expertise
wisely carefully deliberately
looking to add constructively to the
solution of global challenges
so many solutions of which to which are
going to be driven by
data science and ai technologies
and engaging engaging fully as fully as
you can
being part of the global community of
data scientists
there are i mean i i just earlier in the
week got in touch with a group
that's very actively promoting um women
and underrepresented groups in data
science
that's just one example of what you
might choose to get involved in
there's the ieee and all of the
professional societies out there
and there are opportunities surely you
will have opportunities to
to help engage with academic
institutions maybe to help teach some
courses
there's a huge infrastructure that needs
to be built across the world
on behalf of the data science community
and you're now primed to be a part of
that
so the very last thing i'll just say is
to give you a few examples of what our
graduates are doing
uh in the field of data science and ai
at purdue
we send people off to every possible
type of follow-up opportunity
from working at major
technology companies whether they're
more traditional
along the likes of boeing or airbus or
northrop grumman
or whether they're more modern along the
likes of
you know instagram facebook twitter uh
so on and so forth
we send people into positions in policy
and government
we send data scientists off to help
shape policy to help non-profit
organizations do better with their own
data
to help teach non-experts
like members of the legal profession all
of the things they'll need to know about
data science and
our alums are spread out across the
globe
i look very forward to um to meeting
many of you in person at some
point to to continuing to be available
to um
really personally uh to hear from you
over time
i'm well whether it's by email link
about your uh
that you're ready to tackle in your
professional journey
so
very humble person that you know built a
really amazing you know company here
and you know i wouldn't write but
identifies the fortunes 40 under 43
years in a row it's a
very very humble beginning of simply run
which was just a simple blog
and he's created a true global
powerhouse in terms of a company that
hopefully
changes people's lives and that's really
what we live by that's our mantra right
with that said krishna and good morning
and good evening to all of you
with so many masters and psds being here
and
i being the least educated person i
don't want to take a lot of your time
i must congratulate all of you i know a
lot of hard work dedication and
commitment has gone
behind completing this course i have
personally tried
doing a course like this multiple times
but i could never complete it
something or other always came up and i
could never complete the course
successfully but
very excited and energized that i can i
can also definitely give a try and try
to complete a course like this for sure
sometime sometime in future i just want
to tell you
is that when we started thinking about
this program i think
we did a lot of uh discussions and
deliberation internally at simply learn
that will there be takers for a program
like this which we co-create with a
university like purdue
and whether universities will be open to
work with us but fast forward
i think it's been 12 months that we
started doing uh programs like this
and we're really really very excited by
looking at the kind of participants that
were
getting into the program you you being
the first cohort is definitely very very
special to us we will always be keeping
a tap on
what kind of outcome the that this
course provides to you so
as you make progress in your career
please keep us informed here
as dr patrick also mentioned i look
forward to hearing
from you on on linkedin or email
whatever
medium that you want to contact me and
i wish you all the best for your future
career i'm sure
this will definitely help a lot in
achieving the dreams
that you have about your future thank
you
thank you krishna for those kind words
and wise words here um we are going to
do a little bit of a poll
by the way we're going to check before
we go to hear from your peers we're
going to ask a quick question to
everybody
who's here now i am assuming it's a
pretty tough journey that you went
through but we are going to see who are
the people who actually think this was a
breeze and you could just do it really
quickly right
so uh stuart if you don't mind let's
send the poll out a very simple question
now that you're here now that you look
back at the last few months of the
journey that you took
how do you think about that journey was
it an easy journey was it a very
difficult journey i'd like to see how
this scales up in terms of
what your opinion is and we'll give it
up to 30 seconds so
you've got another 20 seconds to go
should be an easy answer for you to give
another 10 seconds
five four three
two one can you see the results please
all right so actually i'm quite
surprised very few people picked
five um you know it seems like somewhere
between three and a four so basically
what you're saying is we should make
these programs even harder
all right but good to hear i think it
also tells me that
the kind of ability that this team has
this set of students
is is uh quite strong and you're able to
get through this
with you know what with what i consider
neither too difficult nor easy nor
fairly difficult right so that's where
you all sit
wonderful now the most exciting part of
it we're going to get into two things
one is you're going to hear from a few
of your peers
who went through this program to hear
what their experience was like and after
that they're going to recognize
all the achievers in this group in terms
of what you've achieved
and we'll celebrate the success of that
team with that said i think we're going
to hand it over to some of your peers
i think the first one we're going to go
with is rina thomas uh if someone can
please unmute reena
and allow her to share her video on
audio that'd be great
is rena ready
all right
oh hello am i ordered yes trina we can
hear you wonderful i don't see your
video yet
uh have you been allowed to open your
video let's see give me a second
go ahead rina yes
okay is my uh we i i guess my video is
still not turned on right i
cannot see your video can someone please
enable her to uh
you know show her video
and we can for a brief moment maybe
remove the slide so we can see
her full screen
thank you
yeah you're part of the uh panel now so
you should be able to open your video
wonderful there you go thank you and
reena thank you for taking the time to
speak to all of us please go ahead
yeah hello everybody uh so i had
enrolled and
simply launched pgp course and data
science in the month of november in the
year 2019 and i completed my course
in the month of august 2020 so let me
just begin by introducing myself
uh i'm currently working as a managing
india bangalore location and my area of
work is focused on content and network
security for cisco customer
and i have nearly three years of
expertise in python uh to speak a little
on why i had chosen data science as my
major and field of study uh as we all
know how fast uh data generation is
growing and how
important uh data analysis is to go to
current business
organizations in fact it has become the
most valuable entity uh
to any business to improve the process
so data science can actually help
improve the
uh by learning the customer requirements
actually analyze the market and also
give you
a kind of prediction on whether so and
we also know how big tech giants like
facebook they use deep text to analyze
the
text or that people the users are
generating on social media platforms
and uh video content providers like
netflix retailers like amazon so all of
them
at some point they do use data science
uh for instance let's take the
recommendation system so
it has improved the customer market ex
so widely
so this was when i had realized that
through my career and to speak a little
on simply launch program in data science
so i felt this had the right set of
skill set that would actually make us
industry ready
so tools like python are tableau
and skills like you know machine
learning natural language
positions these are all these skills
that were up and ready in the market and
it was something that is most in demand
and i would also like to mention that we
had excellent trainers like sonal for
our
natural language processing they had
guided us throughout the process
and we were also given a ton of
practical assignments
so that actually it does really well and
uh it had instilled a great confidence
in us
to actually is the course and uh also i
would like to mention it was a perfectly
paced course to
for working professionals and uh taking
this course has definitely improved my
existing expertise on python modules in
uh in fact like
panda sky kit launch so all of this was
an it was an additional skill set for me
and i would also like to mention that uh
how this course has helped me is that i
was able to
use the chatbot ideas that were
introduced in nlp class and machine
learning model
deploy the models and uh kind of uh you
use it for my organization and improve
the customer experience for the product
that i was
working uh in vipre for and uh also not
also to mention
the cohort group was well selected to
include professionals from various
domains of expertise and i
uh like we had people from banking
networking software
product development consultants
and from all from all areas like we had
junior level professionals mid-level
professionals
senior level professionals so the kind
of knowledge and the mentorship and the
knowledge experience that we gained was
definitely
it was extremely beneficial for me so i
i would like to take this opportunity to
thank patrick and all the trainers
trainers and the panelists who guided us
journey thank you everybody
going forward um i think that's an
amazing story there thank you reena
uh we will now ask dhana lakshmi who is
going to also talk about her experiences
through this uh journey
so panelists if you can kindly allow you
know tadashi
to unmute herself and speak that'd be
great
hello everyone my voice is audible now
yes and lakshmi we can see and hear you
please go ahead okay
uh thank you so much uh thank you uh
all for giving me a chance to speak here
about my
learning experience so i'll introduce
myself
uh myself dana lakshmi uh from bangalore
uh so like uh i have my experience
in sales and marketing for over uh
around 10 years
and different multiple
segments like pharma medical devices and
also our weather products so mostly
in marketing we use the data's huge data
it may be in the different data like
customer data as well as the sales data
where we analyze all the data
to improve our key areas and how to
achieve the profits and the
organizational goals
etc so i came to know about the simply
learn certification program
uh postgraduate program in data
analytics
and i want growth in my career because
i i'm into uh like marketing but
i've done my my background is basically
a science background i completed my
uh graduation and masters of pharmacy uh
but i was a little bit uh want to
need more improvement in my analytic
part so
i got to know about the simply learn
program and
i'm also excited to do so once i
started the program i was really
stuck with the things like the
mathematics the algorithms or statistics
which uh like which is uh uh
like it got uh in my uh school or
college days and it got
again new a chapter for me because after
completing my pharmacy i was into total
different
uh profession so here like
the faculties like nimisha pandey she
has
took classes for python and r and the
data visualization by guru raj so their
faculties are very friendly in manner in
clarifying the doubts uh everything the
programming language because all the
programming language
are totally new to me because
i'm coming from a science background
that's why so but
they have made it very friendly manner
easy manner to understand the
programming language uh like python or
and w
and now i'm i'm really very confident
that
i learned so many things from the uh
this program postgraduate program so
to make my career a growth
in means like now as well as in the
future
so this is my experience with the simply
learn uh
thank you for the program uh dr patrick
and thank you everyone for
uh offered me the chance to
learn some new things because the world
is growing
uh digitally so we means like i also
have want to
make my career also like go very fast in
in this world situation so this helped
me
a very lot so thank you so much all
thank you for
giving me a chance thank you thank you
lakshmi and i think it's amazing that
you're making such a big career jump
and that we were able to help you with
this transition thank you and wish you
all the very very best
thank you so much last but not the least
we're going to invite deborah jyoti who
took our
data analytics course so let's unmute
debut please and then we'll go to awards
uh
okay thank you so much uh so it gives me
emails pleasure to be here at my
convocation and
uh share my thoughts uh hello everybody
this is the
quality assurance analyst with india's
leading i.t services company and
i am serving one of the top insurance
providers in usa
i have six and a half years of work
experience and i'm currently in the
position of a team leader i completed my
graduation in 2014 from sikshana usana
university bhubaneshwar orissa
in the field of electrical engineering
after completion i joined the iit
services company and has been
with them ever since now coming to the
data analytics course that i took
earlier and now that i have completed i
still remember the day
that me was taking this course
all this work from home started and i
started spending more
which led me to a realization so while
scrolling through my linkedin feed
i was super impressed by the profiles
that i came across for my friends or
colleagues
but then when i took a look at my
profile it did not inspire me
let alone what others would have felt
about it so i decided to work on my
profile and make it an inspiring
one by the year end and hence started
the journey
being an i.t employee staying updated
about the latest tech and tools is a
part of everyday job
and being digitally sound is the need of
the r so i started researching a bit and
found data science
machine learning artificial intelligence
deep learning analytics to be the top
trending ones
so on further research i found that i
need to really understand the data first
and then i have to understand what
relevance it holds
and how it is used to find out business
solutions
so that helped me understand that i need
to take up the written analytics course
first
so with this sorted out i now needed to
find out a relevant course
and relevant certifications that will
help me scale up
so i researched again and settled down
with simply learns program
why very simple reasons the program was
in collaboration with one of the top
universities of the world that is purdue
and then again it is in collaboration
with industry leader
ibm to add to this the program consisted
of hands-on learning
instructor-led session realistic
projects and assignments
and the support team was simply amazing
apart from that i found the program to
be absolute value for money
so i guess i had no second opinions
today
now that i have finished the course i
feel immensely accomplished
during this tenure while on one hand i
was able to understand and get trained
in tools and technologies and all of
those stuffs
i also was able to make some amazing
connections in different industries
i am super happy with the overall
experience and the knowledge gain i had
i would like to highlight one particular
instructor that is akshata shetty
who used to say data visualization ted
talks during her classes
and i was simply left inspired
in the end i would like to finish off by
firstly thanking
the instructors of simply learn the team
of simply learn
and dr patrick for occasionally
imparting enlightening sessions
secondly i would like to congratulate
everybody
who is graduating on this convocation
day as well as well wishing for a
rewarding career and finally i would end
by saying
we have miles to go before we sleep and
that each small step taken today is a
step closer to the destination
thank you very much thank you what a
wonderful story
so now here is and wish you all the very
very best in your career i think this is
a great starting point
that you have taken already uh we have
now everybody
uh now you heard three stories we'd like
to hear how much you know
these stories resonated with your own
story and can be a guess it can be a no
my only condition if it's a no then
please go to your chat window and tell
us about your unique story
obviously we can't have every one of you
speak today but we would love to see it
on chat
but let's first answer this question
does any of the story that you heard
today resonate with your own personal
story
love to hear it you've got another 30
seconds to answer this question simple
question
so please do respond
another 15 seconds
five four three two
one all right let's see the results
all right so we have actually a majority
that has a very similar story
and i think there are two stories that
come out of it right people who are
transitioning careers
people who have experience and want to
make a deeper impact and folks who want
to understand the data side and then
grow into the data world right so i
think this makes a lot of sense
um if you have your own unique story
please do put it in the chat window we'd
love to hear the story
uh like i said of course everybody
cannot speak here today we want to keep
it tight and crisp
but we would love to hear the story so
please do add it uh you know
on the chat window now with that said we
are going to go to the exciting part we
are going to start
you know we are going to actually
appreciate all the you know achievers
here
um so why don't we start with the slides
again
all right well wonderful let me start
off by saying first of all
everybody who's completed the course has
already done something
which is beyond what most people
can start something and then it's very
hard for me to complete a program of
this intensity
so first of all everybody's gonna
achieve and let's look at who your peers
and who are the people who have achieved
this today so let's go to the next
screen so you
of course i'm not going to call all the
names out but if you're here give
yourself a round of applause you have
done really well
this is our first cohort you're all very
very special to us so congratulations
all right let's go to the next one
this is the second people
congratulations you've done well you've
gotten here and completed the program
wonderful
all right this is the third slide by the
way just keep in mind for a first
cohort having so many folks graduate
gives you a sense of how important this
program is
and how many people have actually come
here right so congratulations achievers
great work
let's go to the next screen and we're
not done
yet now we come to the people whose
picture we didn't get but
congratulations a lot of people who have
actually graduated today and achieved
this program graduation congratulations
and more five screens of achievers here
thank you so much and congratulations
and wish you all the very best
after this date all right now we get to
the super achievers
so we have two special categories right
and i'll tell you what those two special
categories are let's go to the first one
first one is the folks who actually were
super fast in completing these programs
we call them our speed runners
and these are the people who literally
blazed the trail and completed the
program faster than anybody else
and we are picking basically across
every program there are three learners
that we picked as the fastest learners
uh and there are multiple programs that
are you know graduating today so let's
start first so i'll call out the name
congratulations reena thomas hari
krishnan rishikesh sridhara vishnu
suresh
soviet
congratulations you are among the
speedrunners
wonderful great work completing this
program so fast
we also have jagannath sri prasad
tripuri and ratnesh
congratulations guys great work you're
among the speed runner achievers here
wonderful work
and we have more we have angered deborah
jyoti we just spoke to him
chakri shruti as speedrunners as well
congratulations
all right this is the what i consider
the the last
achiever award and also the folks who
have done
the assessments the projects the best of
all
and so at the end of the day when you
leave this program the biggest learning
you get is in your hands-on experience
the projects you do the the hands-on
experience really matters the most of
all that you learn right
and so we actually want to recognize the
folks who did the best work in their
assessments in their projects
and this is literally the top 10 percent
of the cohort in some sense on
the students who are doing today so
let's go to the you know the folks who
have actually achieved this
congratulations mayank rohan avinash
yasmin
ayman jaladakshi and dr priyank tayabi
congratulations your guys are our
scholars
siddharth
you guys also are among our scholars
this is for ai and ml by the way
artificial intelligence and machine
learning congratulations guys for being
our core
scholar and in data analytics we have
patapou kannada
see who is congratulations
all right so at this point i want to
stop and say
congratulations to everybody while some
folks did get you know special awards i
want to
again remind everybody it's taken you
close to six to nine
nine to 12 months to get to this goal
you all are
every one of you is an achiever
congratulations it's a very difficult
thing to achieve here
but with that said we also want to go to
a little bit of a
you know view of where we are going to
go uh and what is next for you right so
let's talk about that as well
so the first thing i want to talk about
is our
the alumni network so as you know this
program comes with
complementary access to the purdue
alumni network there are specific
communities created on the
purdue community portal you will be
seeing
an email coming to you in the coming
week and this
it will tell you exactly what is how to
join the eleanor network how to get
access to those communities
and be part of these programs but what
also comes with the alumni network is
you can explore job listings you can
connect with fellow alumni there
you can find or become a mentor there
you can share updates and you can join a
community
where you can actually contribute and
learn from across the
entire world right so this is amazing
and these are exclusive communities
created for these programs
and what's even more exciting is as the
next cohorts roll
in and they graduate they're going to
join this community as well
and so what you will see is as you stay
in that community you see
bigger and bigger cohorts of people that
you can learn from and exchange ideas on
so do not lose this chance you know
we'll send you an email uh the next week
for you to actually join this
community the second is your cohort on
simply in communities will also remain
so you're always welcome to continue
having the banter and conversation there
we will absolutely welcome that as well
the second thing i want to talk about
for those of you who care about you know
finding a transition your career i think
there are quite a few of them
we have a live session on resume
building get portfolio creation because
guess what you've done some really
amazing projects through this time
and when you go for a job those git
portfolios your projects that you have
completed
is going to be a big part of what you're
going to talk about so we have two
sessions
one is on the 23rd jan 2021 and another
one on the 13th january january 2021
this will come up as a live session in
your lms in the learner platform
you should be able to log in and find it
this should come in your platform
probably in the next one or two weeks
so we of course you'll get a reminder
you'll get an email you'll know that
this is coming your way
do not miss it make sure that you
actually attend this because it's going
to give you a lot of tips
and this will be hosted by iim jobs so
that you can get the best you know
practices
know how to create a great resume and
portfolio you can position yourself the
best possible way
in finding that dream job that you're
looking for all right
so we want to do a small poll just so
that we can also plan for this
uh how many of you are actually planning
to attend the job fair the
sorry the the webinars that you're
talking about for job
uh if you can create that poll and we
can get a little bit of a sense of how
many folks would
value that it would be good
so the question is there are you
planning to attend these you know resume
and
portfolio creation sessions if so please
do say yes and we'd love to hear
from you we'll give another 15 seconds
10 seconds
another five four three
two one zero all right let's see what
the results are
all right wonderful a majority says yes
which is amazing so we we figured this
would be very interesting to you
uh we look forward to meeting you in
january again after the holidays
and i hope you get a ton of value out of
this and able to find the dream job and
the career transition that you're
looking for wonderful
with that said i want to hand it over to
another very important person
our chief marketing officer mark moran
is going to be addressing this crowd and
giving his closing thoughts mark over to
you
hello everyone um thank you uh again for
everything uh you put into this program
and for
surviving to the end of this closing
ceremony as well
um as uh both anan and rima mentioned
you are very much a diverse and
accomplished group
we have senior executives we have
engineers
we have doctors of philosophy we have
doctors of medicine
we have marketeers we have analysts um
you all have essentially acquired a
set of skills and a scientific mindset
uh to create order from chaos and to
find patterns and insights
from oceans of bits and signals
some of you will apply uh these skills
to create new products and companies
some uh perhaps to uh advanced science
and medicine
uh perhaps even helping us with our next
pandemic
all of you have a chance to have a real
impact on your careers
on your organizations and at society at
large
as they say now the fun begins
first i hope that you're sharing your
accomplishment
with your family with your friends and
with your colleagues
you can inspire them all i wanted to
leave you
with two thoughts from people who are
much more wise and accomplished than me
the first is from
jeff bezos who we all know a founder and
ceo
of amazon what you do what you need to
do
is always lean into the future when the
world changes around you
and when it changes against you what
used to be a tailwind now a headwind
you have to lean into that and figure
out what to do
because complaining isn't a strategy
the second quote i'd like to give is
from peter drucker probably the greatest
business mind of the 20th century
uh short and crisp which is the best way
to predict the future
is to create it and i think that's what
you are all in the midst of doing
is not only in creating your own future
but but uh
helping again your organizations and
society at large
uh with that we wish you all the best
uh as uh dr patrick said
we do we'd love to keep in touch please
reach out and let us know
how you're advancing and use the the
tools uh such as the webinars
um that we we have for you um and and
we'd love to
keep you active in our community as well
there are dozens and hundreds of
learners coming behind you
and you actually can be mentors to them
as you continue on your own journey so
we wish you all the best
thank you again so much for choosing
simply learn we're honored to be
part of your journey and um have a
wonderful weekend
um all the best to all of you take care
thank you mark and to close out and this
is not compulsory but i would humbly
request that if you've had a great
experience and you really are thankful
for what's happened
um there is a small favor that we would
like to ask you if you feel you've got
some great value orders there are two
things i'd like to say
one kindly go to linkedin share your
certificate
make a big deal out of it tell everybody
that you've got this purdue certificate
and that should be you know
coming your way anyway very soon make a
big deal out of it
and the second is if you feel that you
can go one step further and go to switch
up trust file at a course report
and you can talk about your experience
there and i don't care what the rating
is if it's a three out of five it's a
three out of five it's a five out of
five you'll be super happy right
whatever your genuine experiences with
us please put it there
and talk about it we would love for that
as a payback in
some small way uh for you know what
little we have contributed
and we've been immensely grateful for
that with that said i want to wish
everybody here
all the very best in their life i hope
to see you in january when we do the
career sessions
and i'm very confident so i won't even
say all the best i'm very confident you
will do very well
with the certification and the knowledge
you've earned here and with the kind of
cohort that you're with
so stay in touch stay in touch with us
stay in touch with all of the folks that
are there in your cohort
and let's make let's make amazing things
happen in the future thank you so much
have a wonderful day
wonderful night take care bye
you